I know that you had hip surgery left one
when you send me the text of the picture
and you're like leg was up yeah and you
were watching the show yeah yeah yeah
yeah I watch your show all the time
mornings I get to see you see how happy
you are how the energy you give off to
everybody to everyone on the show to the
audience you help me get the pilot we
did that to you and Cameron yep by the
way Cameron will you say hi to Cameron I
haven't seen Cameron in many years her
and I did discuss remaking Planes Trains
and Automobiles and I was like well you
know Adam and I talk about that but yeah
I'd let you do that well also I want to
play John Candy well I you could do a
good candy you know who used to do candy
the best barley when he would walk
around the office and do lines from
Planes Trains you remember hanging out
with all of us at when I had some giant
party at my house I remember looking
over the balcony and it was like Spade
Farley Rock everyone the coolest people
in the world